[Music]
all right what's up mkbhd here and if
you've followed me over the past couple
weeks on twitter or instagram then
you've witnessed it
it's gone down again for the third
straight year the blind smartphone
camera test
2020. so it's originally started as an
idea to sort of crown an unofficial best
unbiased smartphone camera
but as we've learned from doing this
it's turned into a much more
philosophical psychological test
on social media so here's how it works
behind the scenes we take 16 smartphone
cameras that all came out this year and
a good variety too all the way from the
favorites the titans the heavy hitters
all the way down to some mid-range
phones and even budget phones and we
organize them all into a sort of seated
bracket style of what we think is fair
and then we let them loose we label each
one with a letter a through p and then
we go through and take the exact same
photo from the same spot with every
single phone and put them side by side
and have you guys vote on them on
twitter and instagram stories which you
think is better you don't know what
phone you're voting for you just pick a
letter and the final results
are pretty much always
wild and at least a little bit
unexpected just a couple spoilers slash
examples for you
we've done this three years running no
one phone and actually no one company
has ever won more than once and actually
the iphone
has never made it out of the first round
ever now listen this isn't a scientific
test at all matter of fact it's kind of
the opposite of a scientific test a lot
of people on twitter and instagram were
wondering why we didn't do a sample
control photo or something like that
from a dslr
we were just keeping it super simple
bracket style we might be surprised by
the winner but no matter what happens
we're going to learn a lot about the way
our brains work looking at pictures so
with that being said after over 10
million votes this year
let's go over the results so here's the
initial bracket of those letters
and here are the phones behind those
letters so now you can see all of the
first round matchups the way they were
seated and if you want you can go ahead
and pause the video right now and go
ahead and fill out your bracket go ahead
make your predictions knowing which
cameras you think are the best knowing
how they'll compare to each other which
one do you think should go all the way
to the end and come out on top go ahead
all right you've written that down you
didn't fast forward you didn't cheat now
let's go through how the actual bracket
went spoiler alert you're probably wrong
but okay first photo uh was just a
picture of me so i'm wearing a black
shirt i'm in front of a window and
there's plenty of other things to judge
the photo from so there's colors there's
skin tones of course the red controller
the yellow ottoman blue sky blue couch
colorful pillow green plant and lots of
dynamic range happening but at the end
of the day the most scientific part
about this was our goal was to take the
type of photos that most people would
normally take so a lot of human subjects
and you'll see more of that coming up
but also we didn't tap to focus because
what we actually learned from google
after our previous results is they have
a lot of data suggesting most people
don't tap to focus
so we didn't
anyway here's how the first round went
so starting off here with moto edge that
actually beat iphone se right off the
bat
then we have mate 40 pro getting a
pretty huge win over the poco f2 the
poco was kind of a favorite from
previous years but there goes that one
then you have pixel 5 scoring a huge win
over the oppo find x2 pro
then you have lg wing losing to zenfone
7 pro squeaks out that win over here
then on the other side we have surface
duo
never really stood a chance against the
sony xperia 1 mark ii so that was a win
we were probably all expecting
then me 10 ultra did get a win against
the oneplus 8 pro
and iphone 12 pro max
got absolutely destroyed
by the mid-range oneplus 8t
and then last but not least our
defending champ the note one last year
note 20 ultra does get a win over pixel
4a
so go ahead
check your brackets if you still have a
perfect bracket
you're probably lying
but that's that's a lot in one round so
next photo was a dimly lit top down kind
of replicating more like bar lighting
with a warm edison bulb off camera
mixing with far away window light so
again lots of colors and lots of
textures again we made this whole setup
uh not quite dark enough for any of
these phones to kick on night mode and
you even get a little dynamic range test
with the candle in there so with this
next round with a lot of narrowing down
happening already we have mate 40 pro
taking the win over the edge plus
maybe not the biggest upset ever but
those phones are close in price
that's a win for the mate then you have
the zenfone 7 pro squeaking out a win
over the pixel 5.
that i think a lot of people would
consider an upset considering how much
we like pixel 5's camera then over here
me 10 ultra gets the win over sony
xperia 1 mark ii that's a dub
and then the note 20 ultra scored i'm
gonna double check this but i believe
the biggest ever win in the history of
this competition scoring 95 percent of
the votes
against oneplus 8t
so that's a pretty huge win
so now
maybe not so many upsets this round
except maybe pixel losing but again
learning a lot of interesting stuff but
we'll get to that in a second
next round so the semifinals photo was a
good one it's me holding up my r5 which
is all black in front of a couple
different colors yellow cement barrier
red wall black asphalt and then blue sky
behind it and in this one all the photos
by themselves had to focus on the red
ring so you get a nice little depth of
field comparison 2. so in this round we
have zenfone 7 pro
squeaking out a win
over the mate 40 pro
impressively so that that was a close
race a lot of votes on both twitter and
instagram but that was decided narrowly
and then over here we have me 10 ultra
getting the win over note 20 ultra in
the battle of the ultras
so
at this point
we're going to have a new winner because
we had a huawei mate series win the
first year and we had the two samsungs
colliding in the finals last year so
this time they've all been eliminated
for various reasons
and one of these two is going to be the
champ
on the finals so the last round the
pumpkin photo and i think this one it
might just look again like a simple
subject in broad daylight but it has a
lot of stuff here that's taken in mind
stuff we found through the whole contest
there's a method to the madness but
either way when it came down to it
the asus zenfone 7 pro
did squeak out a very narrow win
over
the mi 10 ultra in the finals therefore
crowning it your new people's choice
award
2020 blind smartphone camera test
champion it's december madness
[Music]
okay there's a lot to take in about how
we ended up
here
but first of all from the last two years
the main thing we really got from that
that we learned is that when you put two
photos side by side it brings out a very
specific reaction from people's brains
which is
hold everything else the same
to an extent people will just pick
the brighter photo
makes sense but this year we definitely
got some more nuanced information that's
really important actually now first let
me just say if you were clicking through
the photos and thinking oh this is just
a bunch of pretty simple random photos
without much care put into them
it was kind of designed to look that way
but there's a lot of variables in each
photo
that have a lot to do with the way your
brain perceives that photo a lot of
different colors a lot of different
focal lengths backgrounds
style of photo we didn't get to do
action photos or night photos but
there's some really good stuff in here
so from all this i think there's three
main things that we picked up
one
we have a new winner
two
white balance
is underrated
and three
twitter versus instagram
[Music]
so first of all yes the new winner is
the asus zenfone 7 pro probably pretty
surprising winner for most people
guessing most of you didn't have this
winning the bracket although if you were
paying attention last year this one took
some great photos and only lost by a
slim margin but it's got an improved
triple camera system this time the 64
megapixel main camera that bends down to
16 megapixel photos and there's also
they toss in a 3x telephoto and an ultra
wide nothing too crazy except for the
fact that the cameras flip around and
become probably the best selfie camera
in any phone which is sick so it's not
the most extreme crazy 100 megapixel
camera or anything like that but
if you go back through the rounds while
some had random white balance misses or
some artifacting or would just blow out
a photo dynamic range something would go
wrong once in a while
you know this phone
just kind of had a clean consistent
exposure each time just didn't miss this
[ __ ] don't miss no he's [ __ ]
good that [ __ ] don't miss man
he's good
in the heat of battle he don't miss no
[Music]
okay so white balance has been a major
key new factor from our understanding
from the smartphone bracket this year
and i'd go so far as to say that it
looks like this has been the reason that
the iphone has lost in the first round
every single time see the other thing we
learned putting photos side by side is
if you have brightness the same and all
of the things the same
people will choose the photo that's a
little bit more saturated a little more
vibrant looking
which also makes sense but it's to an
extent you can't just crank saturation
all the way through the roof but
generally if you have two photos that
are almost the same and one of them
looks a little more pale it'll lose so
we know
what white balance is right it's
generally how warm or how cool a photo
or video will look and a good white
balance has pure white looking like pure
white now the nuance with white balance
is this
in photos that have more warm colors
more reds orange yellow that type of
thing
the warmer the white balance
the more saturated it will actually make
those warm colors feel
and the less saturated it will actually
make those cool colors feel and the
opposite is also true so in a photo with
lots of cool colored things a cooler
overall white balance will make those
things look more saturated by a bit and
those warm things will look less
saturated so stay with me so in this
first photo white balance was a major
deciding factor because many of the
colors in the frame are warm you have my
warmer skin tone the yellow ottoman the
red piece here the red controller and
even the sunlight streaming in onto the
wall behind me and a lot of smartphones
are all over the place with white
balance even from shot to shot but when
they go too cool
my black shirt starts to go blue my skin
looks less saturated a little bit more
pale and the whole photo shifts
this is the iphone 12 pro max's first
round shot and you know there is a lot
of detail and sharpness sure but it's by
far the coolest temperature and plus the
whole boosted exposure is so bright that
it also blows out the sky behind me
which would have looked even more blue
if you could see it because of the
cooler temperature that is of course
very different from the oneplus photo
that beat it so really the question is
why does the iphone and why do some
phones so consistently have such a cool
hue a blue tint to the white balance
and obviously i'm not behind the scenes
your guess is probably as good as mine
but my theory would be
that on photos of people with fairer
skin tones which is most people it
doesn't affect the skin tone look quite
as much you can get away with it and
also blue skies will look more blue than
it would if you were biasing warm second
round there was a lot happening and i
think the number one factor most people
settled on was just how much of the
candle they could see in that photo and
that's just a straight up dynamic range
test and in every match up the photo
with more dynamic range one but also
everything in the photo is pretty warm
the candle is orange the salad has some
reds in it the yellow lemon and even of
course the wood table everything is
sitting on lots of good little details
in the bread and the lettuce and the
place mat to pick up on here then in the
third round we have a lot of again
neutral and warmer colors we have my
hand with the skin tone we have the
black camera with the red ring we have
the asphalt in the background so we have
the four remaining phones but i took a
reference photo on the iphone just for
fun and it was blue man i feel like it
would have lost in this round again if
it got this far in the first place
because it was so blue now a
photographer looking through a lot of
these i had some photographer friends
messaging me as this was going on a
photographer looking at this would
probably not be so concerned about white
balance because at the end of the day
that's just a slider you can fix
and even exposure as long as it's
somewhat accurate that's a slider you
can fix what we really want is as much
information as possible as much detail
and dynamic range so that you can make
the photo you want in the edit
and that's one way of thinking about the
photo i think the other way is just hey
this is a compressed photo on social
media just do the best you can with it
and speaking of compression
so
this blind test was held on both
instagram stories
and twitter where you could do votes
and it turns out what we learned is
instagram stories and twitter compress
and show your photos in very different
ways so this was the final round photo
comparison it's a photo of an orange
pumpkin it's like the perfect finale
photo given everything we've been
learning about white balance and warmth
through this whole time but here i'm
waiting to see if you know the photo
with the warmer white balance
looks more saturated with the pumpkins
and wins and sure enough the bottom
photo by the me10 ultra is looking more
saturated in that side by side so as we
post it i'm expecting more people to
vote for that and on instagram it won
but on twitter
it got crushed
and that
was a weird moment where i was i was
trying to
like figure out why that would happen in
my head maybe i thought because everyone
on twitter has been sort of hyper
analyzing this and commenting and
replying for so long that by the time
you get to the finals people are
scrolling down the comments and looking
at people's talk before they vote
and i guess instagram stories is just a
pure vote no comments
but it was just such a big difference
this guy won by about 30 000 votes on
instagram and the zen phone won by about
90 000 votes on twitter so that means
overall the zenfone did win the finals
but that was that was a big swing so it
turns out
and shout out to the people who are
voting on both that sent this to me
instagram stories
looks different from twitter images see
the images uploaded to twitter actually
look like they both got a boost to
saturation to the point where the bottom
photo actually looked over saturated and
people overwhelmingly voted for the
zenfone for staying realistic while it
looked like the me ultra was way over
the top
then on instagram it actually made both
photos a little bit more pale so the top
zen phone actually looked too pale and
the bottom photo which looked closer to
realistic got more votes really
fascinating stuff which again dumps more
gasoline on my fire theory that
it doesn't really matter exactly what
your photo looks like when you take it
and when you edit it as long as you like
it
post that
so moral of the story am i going to go
running out and telling people zenfone 7
pro is the new king of smartphone
cameras
no
but it is very consistent so i'll give
it that and if you care about that in a
smartphone camera you won't be
disappointed with that phone but
generally
the point is everywhere on the internet
you post a photo it's just gonna look
different this is even true with videos
actually when i post a video on youtube
it looks different on my computer versus
by the time it gets chewed up and spit
out through youtube on your monitor or
someone else's phone or someone else's
laptop and this is also true about all
our photos and different social media
platforms so at the end of the day
just make what you want to make
post it
and be happy with that don't worry too
much about the tools themselves do the
best you can with what you've got
because that's what we're all doing at
the end of the day
[Music]